hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd and
fan of gadgets
i've had a lot of people ask me to talk
about microcurrent devices
you've probably seen these on social
media they're these little electronic
devices handheld
that have two metal balls on them for
rayo have launched a couple of
microcurrent devices the bear and the
bear mini
they've partnered with me to do a video
on how microcurrent works
i'm going to talk about the science
behind how microcurrent works
how to use the device how it feels on
your skin and what results i've gotten
i've been using it every night for three
and a half weeks on just this side of my
face so i'm feeling pretty asymmetric
right now
if you like noting out about the science
behind beauty products click the like
the subscribe and click the notification
bell so you don't miss any videos
[Music]
so firstly what is microcurrent
microcurrent is basically a really weak
flow of electricity
generally it's so weak that you won't be
able to feel it or you'll barely be able
to feel it there are a couple of types
of microcurrent device on the market
i've talked about the ionophoresis
devices before this is where the current
goes from the device through your face
and then down your body and back along
your arm to complete the
circuit this type of device is mostly
for pushing skin care into your skin
the microcurrent devices i'm talking
about today have both of the electrodes
on your face
and so it completes the circuit through
a very short portion of your skin
these devices have currents in the 10 to
500 microamp range so for reference one
milliamp or 1000 microamps
is how much you need to be able to feel
it that's the detection threshold
with 10 milliamps or 10 000 microamps
that will give you a painful electric
shock
[Music]
so how does microcurrent work this is
actually a pretty complicated question
there are a lot of benefits that
microcurrent devices claim to have
these ones are the most common ones it
tightens and smooths your skin
it tones contours and lifts your face
you get more defined cheekbones and
jawline
it boosts collagen and elastin it
reduces fine lines and wrinkles
boosts circulation increases cellular
activity and decreases puffiness
the biggest problem is that there aren't
many direct studies on humans using
these microcurrent devices that you get
on the market
to firstly back up the claims but also
to give us a better idea of how they
actually work so let's talk about the
background behind what microcurrent
could potentially do so we can
understand what to realistically expect
and demystify some of the jargon behind
these microcurrent devices
[Music]
a lot of things in your body run on
electricity and what electricity really
is
is a flow of charged particles in a
metal wire you have lots of negatively
charged electrons and these can move
along
to create an electric current in your
body you don't have a lot of free
electrons but you do have a lot of
charged ions
and these can move along and create an
electric current
you might have heard of electrolytes and
sports drinks those contain
a lot of the eyes that your body uses
for electricity obviously since our
bodies aren't zapping around everywhere
interfering with our electronics
bioelectricity is at a pretty low level
it's in the micro amp level
and that's what's in microcurrent so how
does microcurrent work
[Music]
the most obvious thing that microcurrent
devices do is
increase the size of your muscles this
effect is pretty much immediate and if
you keep on using it the effect becomes
longer lasting and so that's why
you might have heard that microcurrent
devices are like a workout for your face
your face muscles getting buff and swell
explains a lot of the effects that
people see from using microcurrent
devices
as you get older your muscles start to
shrink and that's what contributes to
the saggy look the loss of plumpness and
the loose skin
that we associate with older faces with
microcurrent your muscles get bigger and
so you end up with a younger look
because the muscle's bigger it stretches
out the skin and so that ticks off our
tightened skin
and reduces fine lines and wrinkles
because the muscle is firmer and bigger
it tones contours and lifts your face
plus you get more defined cheekbones and
jawline
but why exactly does microcurrent make
your muscles get bigger and how long
lasting should we expect this effect to
be
this is where it gets sort of murky and
the science gets a bit vague
one possible explanation is that the
microcurrent is strength training your
muscles like you're exercising them
your body uses electricity for a lot of
things and the most obvious one is
sending signals through your nerves
it's electrical impulses from your
nerves that make your muscles contract
and that's how your body moves
when you exercise a muscle you put it
under strain and this strain signals to
the body through a combination of
tension microscopic damage and metabolic
stress that it needs to produce more
protein more muscle
to deal with this extra work but it
takes about a week between exercise
for your muscles to start actually
growing but the effect of microcurrent
is pretty immediate
so this immediate effect is something
that happens in strength training as
well
it's often called a pump and this is
when your muscles get temporarily
super super swoll right after you work
out because it's getting swollen up from
extra water and extra blood this also
increases tension
and this can signal again to the body
that it needs to produce more muscle
normally when it comes to muscle growth
with electrical stimulation though it's
most effective
when the muscle actually contracts
properly this is the basis of ems or
electrical muscle stimulation which are
those
electric shock machines that you might
have seen on some late night infomercial
and microcurrent isn't like that your
muscles shouldn't be visibly contracting
so it doesn't seem like this would
completely explain how microcurrent
works
the other common explanation for how a
microcurrent could potentially work
is by increasing atp production you
might have heard that the mitochondria
is the powerhouse of the cell
that's because it produces atp atp or
adenosine triphosphate is one of the
main chemical sources of energy in your
body
mitochondria make atp from nutrients
that you get from food
and atp is used to fuel lots of
biological processes in your body
so things like production of protein
moving eyes around and muscle
contractions
one of the things that tends to happen
as you get older is that your
mitochondria function less effectively
and so you produce less atp and this
also happens if you use your muscles
less
now the production of atp requires a
flow of iron so an electric current
and that's where our microcurrent comes
in and so it turns out that supplying a
small current from the outside so 10 to
1000 microamps for two hours
on rat skin could actually increase atp
production by up to 500 percent
this is the origin of the claim that
microcurrent devices can recharge your
cells or provide cellular energy
the production of proteins is affected
as well electrical differences across
membranes affects how amino acids
are moved around amino acids are the
building blocks of proteins
so in the same study currents between
100 and 750 microamps
increase the transport of amino acids
into cells and so both of these effects
can contribute to protein production
and muscle growth interestingly in this
study when they use 1 000 microamps or
one milliamp which you might remember is
the smallest amount that you can feel
there's actually decreased protein
synthesis and so more isn't
actually better when it comes to
electricity the flow of ions can also
change how water moves around inside
your muscle
and so that could explain the immediate
plumping effect so the problem is that
there isn't much evidence that what
happens in these samples of rat skin
also happens on your face even though
it's quite plausible
and there's some evidence from animal
and human studies that microcurrents can
increase muscle growth so it's probably
a combination of the strength training
effects and the atp
production effects and probably some
other things as well that lead to these
muscle
increased benefits of microcurrent now
with the other claims the fact that
you're massaging your face with these
devices could explain some of the other
things like
boosting circulation and decreasing
puffiness with the collagen and elastin
increase effects
the theory is that since you have more
atp and atp is used for everything
including collagen and elastin
production
then having more of it around will lead
to increases in collagen and elastin
so is microcurrent worth it all in all
microcurrent has a really dramatic
immediate effect
and potentially some longer-term
anti-aging benefits as well
but those longer term effects aren't
really well tested
and so there's no guarantee that they'll
actually happen but i think there are
still some really big things going for
microcurrent
the biggest advantage is that it targets
stuff that you can't actually reach with
skin care products
to deal with changes in your face based
on muscles you'd normally need to go to
botox fillers and surgery
so when we're looking at the cost and
the time investment we shouldn't be
comparing microcurrent devices to skin
care products
we should be comparing them to botox
fillers and surgery and when we make
that
comparison microcurrent isn't actually
that expensive there's also a small time
investment
and minimal side effects at the very
least there's a short-term lifted
appearance that only takes about two or
three minutes to make and that lasts for
a decent amount of time so half a day or
full day that's enough to make a
difference to your appearance that would
be really hard to achieve
otherwise and so if you compare that to
putting on makeup daily
then it's not a huge time investment the
potential long-term effects would be a
really great bonus but i think
even if you only believe in the
immediate effects
it can be worth it especially if your
face is starting to droop a bit
and of course if you'll actually end up
using the device the really good thing
is that you can quickly see what the
effects will be like and whether or not
you like them so
after the first time you use it you'll
get a good preview of what to expect
and so it's not like a lot of skin care
products where you have to wait for
weeks or months to see if that
investment is actually worth it
one other popular non-invasive way of
getting bigger face muscles
is facial yoga this is where you do a
whole bunch of face exercises to like
schwarzenegger up your face
and i think microcurrent has a few
advantages over this
first it's less time consuming you're
only meant to use microcurrent devices
for less than five minutes a day
whereas facial exercises you're meant to
do for 30 minutes or so
there's also the fact that you often
can't purposely exercise the muscles
that you want to exercise
we tend to get trained into unconscious
patterns of what muscles we like to use
and it's really hard to untrain that
if you've ever been to a physiotherapist
you know that a lot of it is desperately
trying to clench muscles that you
haven't been clenching right your whole
life
if you do the facial exercises correctly
then you should be targeting the right
muscles and not over exercising the ones
that are already really swoll
but with microcurrent it's a lot easier
just to shove the device on there
and target the correct muscle facial
exercises also make you contort your
face
a lot and unfortunately repetitive
facial movements
is how we etch a wrinkle into our skin
that's why a lot of wrinkles are called
expression lines so this is things like
crow's feet from smiling marinette lines
and smokers lines from pursing lips it's
a bit like how you end up with the most
wrinkles on a leather wallet in the
places that you bend the most
so facial exercises could be deepening
your wrinkles while it's plumping up
your face
with microcurrent your face doesn't
actually move and so that's not an issue
the downside with microphone is that you
actually have to go and buy a device and
it's a bit harder to use it while you're
driving
[Music]
so onto at-home devices there are quite
a few on the market and
obviously they're a bit weaker than the
in-clinic versions and so it's
recommended that you use these close to
every day
this is the fro bear and this is the
ferro bear mini
they are both pretty small and portable
the bear is a bit larger and so that's
meant for all over face
treatment whereas the mini is smaller
it's meant for more targeted treatment
like around your lips
both of these have spherical electrodes
and a silicone body and so you can
actually wash these with soap and water
as well as the microcurrent both of
these have foreo's t-sonic pulsations
which you might already know from luna
and ufo these are meant to massage your
face and help your products absorb
better
you can adjust the intensity of the
microcurrent so this has five
levels this has three and you can turn
the t-sonic pulsations on and off the
bear has a special safety feature which
is the anti-shock system
this scans your skin resistance a
hundred times per second
and it adjusts the current to suit it in
0.002
seconds so this guarantees a shock-free
treatment which is good if you're a bit
scared of microcurrent devices
it doesn't make it any less powerful
though the bear is actually more
powerful than a lot of other
microcurrent devices on the market
it operates at a higher frequency with
50 pulses per second
i've been using the bear on just the
right side of my face every night for
the last three weeks and i'm actually
really happy i'm making this video now
because i can finally even my face up
again to me the results are pretty
dramatic but i think that's because i
know my face and i can feel my face
i think to everyone else it's pretty
subtle so firstly when i smile it feels
a lot tighter on my right side
so it's a little bit like how after
you've exercised for a while and your
muscles have gotten toned you feel like
they're a lot more
firmer and more in control when i poke
my cheeks the right side also feels a
bit firmer
if i tilt my head forwards the
nasolabial fold here is also a bit
less deep i also try to use this
headband to
apply equal pressure on both sides but i
think the problem
is it's never quite in exactly the right
spot and so it's really hard to see the
[Music]
comparison
so i thought i'd use the bail on my left
side which hasn't had a microcurrent
treatment for a few months and then i'll
talk through
how to use it how it feels and then we
can see if we can see a difference
so you want to start with a clean dry
face so that the current isn't
interrupted when it flows through the
device and through your skin
when it's flowing correctly then you
shouldn't be able to feel much on your
face maybe it'll feel a little bit
firmer but that's about it
now electricity likes to take the path
of least resistance and so that means
through the more watery areas of your
face like the deeper skin tissues
and the muscle but the dead skin on the
surface of your face is quite dry
and so you want to wet that and that's
why you need to use a gel
most microcurrent brands have their own
gel so foreo has serum serum serum which
is a really nice hyaluronic acid serum
you can also use aloe vera gel or
ultrasound gel
the problem i found with every jello
tried is that if you put it all over
your face at the start
then it dries out by the time you get to
other parts of your face
and if it does dry out then it doesn't
conduct properly and it can start giving
this little prickly feeling
so i find it easiest to apply the gel to
one area only and treat it and then move
on to the next spot
the prickling feeling isn't really
painful it's a bit uncomfortable it
feels a bit like being snapped with a
tiny tiny rubber band
it tends to happen when you don't have
enough gel or if you're moving over like
a hair which is interfering with how
well that electrode makes contact with
your skin
you need to download the ferrari app to
activate the devices and then you can
either follow the routine in the app or
you can just
adjust it yourself with the button right
now there's only one routine in the app
but there are more coming
i'd recommend using the routine in the
app the first couple of times and the
bear will adjust the intensities for you
automatically but it's honestly pretty
easy to use and so i usually just use it
with the button
i usually watch another video on youtube
while i do it and i keep an eye on the
timestamp so i can keep track of how
long i've been using it
this does also turn off automatically
after three minutes
i start with applying the gel
and then you turn on the bear with
by just pressing the button so the
number of
that buzzing noise is the t sonic
pulsations i'm going to turn that off
for now
and so you double click it really fast
the lights here tell you
how intense the microcurrent is so right
now it is going at three even though
it's not making any noise
if you want to adjust the intensity you
just press the button quickly
once and it will increase it will cycle
through all five levels
so you're meant to lightly press the
spheres onto your face
and both of them should be touching and
you just glide it up so i can't actually
feel anything even though
i am on the second intensity and this
half of my face has never well hasn't
really had microcurrent for like months
so when the two spheres are touching
your face you can actually see the
middle light turn off
to show that you're doing it properly
and so if that light stays
on it means it the current's not running
[Music]
[Music]
so to turn it off you just hold down the
button for a few seconds
so you glide it upwards wherever you're
using it on your face avoid the eye area
and the middle of your neck and yeah
it's pretty straightforward
one thing i really appreciate about
these fourier devices is that you don't
have to recharge them a lot so i've been
using the bear on a single charge for
the whole three and a bit weeks now it
says you can use it for 90 uses per
charge and charging it takes 90 minutes
when you do charge it it's really nice
and simple as well you just plug it into
a usb cable there there's no
awkward bulky cradle or anything so
smelling already feels a bit tighter
i can feel the muscles here um
activating more than before it turns out
it's stupidly hard to smile the exact
same amount at the exact same
angle for comparison and i only did
three minutes on a lower setting
but hopefully you can see some
differences the cheek is a bit more
defined the jawline is sharper and more
symmetrical
it's a bit hard to tell but i was having
trouble smiling evenly before because
the two sides felt so different
but after doing my left side as well it
feels a lot more natural
i don't think my mouth is really
symmetrical at the best of times but
comparing me talking before and after
you can see how it's evened out now i'm
really awkward about how i've been
walking around for weeks super lopsided
instead of regular lopsided
so that's microcurrent have you tried it
what did you think do you have any tips
for getting the best results out of your
microcurrent device leave them in the
comments
as always i hope you liked this video if
you did you can click the like and the
subscribe
you can also follow me on instagram and
check out my blog lab muffin beauty
science for more on the science behind
beauty products
thanks to foreo for sponsoring this
probably unexpectedly deep
dive into microcurrent devices and i
will see you next time to nerd out more
you